es ist ein albtraum wenn ein
polizeieinsatz so endet wie jetzt in
dortmund dort hat die polizei selbst
tödliche schüsse abgegeben und der tote
ist erst 16 jahre alt was ist da
passiert bei diesem einsatz in der
dortmunder nordstadt
dramatische szenen in dortmund ein
jugendlicher greift die polizei mit
einem messer an die beamten erschießen
ihn der tote ist erst 16 jahre alt um
16.25 spitzt sich der einsatz in der
dortmunder nordstadt dramatisch zu
holsteiner straße auf dem abgesperrten
kirchengelände trifft mindestens eine
kugel den teenager laut
bild-informationen ein senegalese er
bricht schwer getroffen auf dem
kirchengelände st antonius zusammen wo
er in einer jugendgruppe lebte der 16
jährige kommt in die klinik noch während
der not-operation hört sein herz auf zu
schlagen bild weiß der jugendliche hat
zunächst in suizidaler absicht das
messer angesetzt stiche in den eigenen
bauch angedeutet die beamten wollten ihn
mit einem taser stoppen dann soll er im
hof der kirche aber plötzlich auf sie
losgegangen sein und
wir sprechen jetzt mit bild chefreporter
frank schneider dort in dortmund am
tatort größte die ich frank diese
tödlichen polizeischüsse die schlagen
inzwischen ruhe und der tote
schwarzafrikaner der tote erst 16 jahre
alt nach allem was du weisst gab es für
die polizei wirklich keine andere
möglichkeit als auf diesen jungen zu
schießen
das können wir noch nicht genau
endgültig sagen aber momentan sieht es
wirklich so aus als wenn es eine
notwehrsituation gewesen wäre ich stehe
hier an der stelle wo gestern diese
schüsse gefallen wir können einmal
zeigen es ist hier die st antonius
gemeinde und dort ist auch die kirche
der kollege filmt einmal in diesem
innenhof und in diesem innenhof hat
gestern der polizeieinsatz begonnen sah
es nämlich so dass nämlich dort dieser
jugendliche 16 jahre aus dem senegal mit
einem messer gestanden hat die anwohner
und auch mitarbeiter einer jugendhilfe
gruppe die hier an dieser
kirchengemeinde in einem haus ist haben
die polizei verständigt und auch den
rettungsdienst weil dieser junge
psychische auffälligkeiten zeigte schon
den letzten tagen und eben auch geäußert
er wolle sich um dann soll er gestern
hier nur verstanden haben mit einem sehr
langen messer man spricht von einer
klingenlänge von 15 bis 20 zentimetern
und hat angedroht sich selbst getötet
hat immer wieder stichbewegungen
richtung bauch angedeutet so sagen die
augenzeugen und die polizeibeamten und
dann wollten die polizei waren ihn
eigentlich retten sie wollten verhindern
dass er sich umbringt und dann ist
folgendes passiert sie haben dann als
sie merken er lässt sich nicht beruhigen
er ist in so einer psychischen
ausnahmesituation erstmal fast break
eingesetzt das ist ja die niedriges der
eskalationsstufe das hat nichts bewirkt
dann sollen sie auch den taser das ist
ja nordrhein-westfalen relativ neu diese
these die die polizei auch hat
eingesetzt haben das soll auch nichts
gebracht haben und dann soll die
situation plötzlich total eskaliert sein
der jugendliche soll losgerannt sein auf
die polizeibeamten losgegangen sein mit
diesem messer und ist dann hier über
diesen zaun wir können das noch mal
zeigen wo wir gerade den hof gefilmt
haben und der kameramann kann dann noch
mal rüber schwenken dann sehen wir hier
am boden gleich nämlich die nummern die
sind hier noch angezeichnet wir sehen
hier einmal die nummer vier und ein
stück weiter sehen wir dann die nummer
fünf und sechs hier vorne im
sonnenschein und da ist es nämlich so
gewesen dass die polizeibeamten hier
dann geschossen haben dort lagen hülsen
daran sieht man wie auf die polizei dann
doch hat geschossen hat oder schießen
musste das müssen jetzt die ermittlungen
klären jedenfalls ist ja wohl über
diesen zaun und auch die polizeibeamten
die hier zur sicherung stand losgegangen
und die wussten sich in der situation
wohl nicht anders zu helfen als eben zu
schießen und die ermittlungen liegen
jetzt bei der polizei in recklinghausen
und bei der staatsanwaltschaft in
dortmund die obduktion wird heute mittag
sein und dann muss man genau klären
woran ist er gestorben wo es ja
getroffen worden wie viele kugeln haben
ihn getroffen und der einsatz
aufbereitet werden
franck weiß so zu den hintergründen
dieses jungens erst 16 jahre alt dort
offenbar auch untergebracht welche
informationen hast du über ihn über das
todesopfer
wir wissen bislang es handelt sich um
einen 16 jährigen jugendlichen aus dem
senegal der wohl als flüchtling
unbegleitet hier hingekommen ist
jedenfalls hat er in dieser wohngruppe
wohl alleine gelebt ob ihre familie
hatte sich wissen wir zum 10 zeit noch
nicht die kirchengemeinde möchte
momentan nichts sagen die stehen alle
unter großen schock weil sie eben auch
dem jugendlichen helfen wollten wussten
jetzt nicht gut deshalb ist denn diese
jugendhilfeeinrichtungen und das da
gestern so eskaliert ist damit konnte
keiner rechnen meinte die polizei
gerufen und den rettungsdienst der mitte
junge gerettet wird und am ende ist er
jetzt doch tot und das wollte eben
keiner und man merkt hier einen großen
schock in der kirchengemeinde und woher
der junge wirklich stammt aber hier auch
in dortmund vorgelebt hat das konnte uns
bislang noch keiner sagen bzw eben in
der kirchengemeinde wollte uns niemand
sagen weil sie sagen wir müssen erstmal
selber das erlebte von gestern abend
verarbeiten ja mit frank innerhalb
weniger tage viele tote nach
polizeieinsätzen in köln dort um die
ecke zuvor auch in frankfurt ein toter
nach einem polizeieinsatz jetzt dieser
fall in dortmund alles unterschiedliche
fälle und trotzdem diese ballung von
fällen innerhalb weniger tage dafür
spricht dass nach deiner erfahrung die
du immer ja ein enges ohr an der polizei
hass dafür dass die waffe möglicherweise
schneller gezückt wird ist das reiner
zufall oder spricht das dafür dass die
polizisten im einsatz aber noch häufiger
bedroht werden
also ich glaube die waffe wird häufiger
gezückt aber eben auf der gegenseite
nicht die polizeibeamten sie lernen ja
eben ganz bewusst in der ausbildung das
sogenannte nicht schießen es ist ja das
ziel der polizei beim auf keinen fall
die schusswaffe einzusetzen außer das
geht überhaupt nicht mehr anders und was
wir in den letzten jahren beobachtet
haben ist eine zunehmende
respektlosigkeit gegenüber
polizeibeamten und dazu eben auch immer
häufiger einsatz von waffen und dabei
handelt es sich häufig um ein messer das
war in köln ja nicht anders er hatte
einen schraubendreher und ein messer
hier hatte der jugendliche auch ein
messer und viel unterschätzen das gibt
ja ein aufschrei auch schon im social
media nach dem motto wie kann man auf
einen 16 jährigen schließen der ja nur
ein messer hat man muss wissen gerade in
der ausbildung wird das ja trainiert ein
sogenannter messer täter ist viel
gefährlicher häufiger als ein täter mit
einer schusswaffe weil die überwinden
halt kurze distanzen in ganz ganz
schneller ja in 230 kunden und die
polizeibeamten können sich gegner messer
kaum wehren sie können schlecht
eingreifen haben eben gehört eine
klingenlänge von 15 bis 20 zentimeter
diese messer wirken halt im ersten stich
möglicherweise tödlich und die beamten
tragen zwar schutzwesten ja aber wenn
zum beispiel ein messer eindringt
entlang der schutzweste dort wo der arm
raus kommt eben unter der schulter oder
eben auch ins gesicht oder in den hals
geht dann sind die polizei war
möglicherweise beim ersten stich tödlich
verletzt und deshalb müssen sie häufig
eben auch mit der schusswaffe agieren
und das ist ein großes problem genau
deshalb hatte die polizei in nordrhein
westfalen jetzt diesen tesa angeschafft
um eben eine niedrigere eskalationsstufe
zu haben um eben nicht schießen zu
müssen warum das gestern abend nicht
gereicht hat warum der jugendliche
offenbar unbeeindruckt war von diesem
thema das müssen jetzt noch mal die
ermittlungen und die obduktion klären
danke ganz kurz nach der die schlüssel
kann jetzt in dortmund aus einer
maschinenpistole sagt dass du uns und
das ist
ja das klingt erst mal ungewöhnlich aber
die polizei führt diese maschinenpistole
seit vielen jahren wieder mit früher
hatte die jeder streifen waren
mittlerweile hat die polizei die auch
wieder dabei aufgrund der terrorgefahr
man muss aber wissen die polizei
erschießt die gleiche munition mit ihrer
dienstwaffe der dienstpistole wie auch
mit dieser maschinenpistole mp5 das ist
ein 99 mm wird patrone und man die
maschinenpistole wird häufig eingesetzt
bei größeren distanzen weil sie genauer
schießt weil man eben auch vermeiden
will den täter tödlich zu verletzen ihn
erstmal nur kampfunfähig zu schießen
hier was gestern noch so dass die erste
meldung war der jugendliche ist zwar
schwer verletzt kommt ins krankenhaus
aber es besteht keine lebensgefahr warum
er dann drei stunden später in der
klinik während der not-op doch
verstorben ist das muss eben heute den
op die obduktion klären denn die not-op
raja damit das leben zu retten aber
genau dort ist ja dann verstorben und da
muss man sehen ob es möglicherweise so
starke innere verletzungen waren eine
junge 16 jahre alt ein schwarzafrikaner
senegalese wird von der polizei
notwehrsituation in dortmund erschossen
danke für alle hintergründe an unseren
chefreporter frank schneider polizei
großeinsatz beim ex us präsidenten das
fbi hat vor wenigen stunden das anwesen
von donald trump durchsucht so etwas
eine solche fbi untersuchung
durchsuchung bei einem ehemaligen us
präsidenten so etwas gab es noch nie
razzia bei trump am abend um 18 uhr da
steht das fbi vordertür einsatzort
malabo florida das riesen anwesend von
donald trump die polizei sucht
geheimdokumente papiere aus dem weißen
haus die champ angeblich privat einfach
mit nach hause genommen haben soll das
fbi jump doch einer ist nicht da trance
selbst der ex präsident bestätigt aus
new york city den polizeieinsatz bei ihm
zu hause und erschöpft sein anwesen
befindet sich im belagerungszustand
so etwas sei keinem anderen us
präsidenten jemals angetan worden trump
weiter diese unangekündigte
durchsuchungen meines hauses war weder
notwendig noch angemessen und auch trump
sohn eric schmidt im interview mit fox
news
sie haben ihn verleugnet sie haben ihm
herabgesetzt sie sind hinter ihm her
hinter uns ein es gibt in der geschichte
der usa keine familie der öfter in den
rücken geschossen wurde als der jump
familie schauen sie sich den
generalstaatsanwalt bezirksstaatsanwalt
im ganzen land sie alle wollen donald
trump clan kriegen hat der us-präsident
geheime dokumente einfach aus dem weißen
haus mitgenommen es geht um diese
momente den abschied aus dem weißen haus
trump steigt in den hubschrauber mit
dabei ganze kisten akten geheimdokumente
geheime briefe auch von vorgänger obama
der us sender foxnews sagt nein das ist
rache
an dem ex-präsidenten trump anhänger
wütend sie haben sich längst zu
hunderten auf den weg nach florida
gemacht bilder aus der nacht wie eine
bürgerwehr ziehen die tram fans in
malaga
und unser us korrespondent herbert
bauernebel ist jetzt dort wo sich jump
selbst gerade aufhält in new york
herbert das erschüttert oder ja
zumindest südamerika heute auf ist das
notwendige polizeiuntersuchung oder ist
das alles wie fox news berichtet wrx
sagt alles politisch schikane sogar eine
art politischer rache und dann muss man
natürlich sehen welche seite des
politischen spektrums man steht wenn man
ein kritiker ist es präsident ehemaligen
präsidenten trump wird man natürlich
sagen ja das geschieht ihm recht das ist
absolut gerechtfertigt einfach man kann
privat unterlagen aus der zeit des
weißen hauses nicht einfach mitnehmen
seine verteidiger die republikaner und
viele seiner sehr loyalen anhängern
sagen natürlich das ist eine weitere
aktion wo eben die andere seite versucht
einen krieg gegen baumann tram zu führen
und ihm zu schaden besonders in einer
zeit wo er sich möglicherweise auf seine
nächste präsidentschaftskandidatur
vorbereiten könnte und welche dokumente
soll es da gehen wird irgendwas
spezielles vermisst
das volumen wird beschrieben mit
ungefähr 15 kisten die eben hier in marl
lage aufgetaucht sein sollen die genauen
inhalte sind unklar sind teilweise ja
unterlagen papiere auch möglicherweise
kleine geschenke tonträger andere dinge
dass eben wird jetzt versucht umzukehren
auch mit hilfe des fbi jetzt denn
offensichtlich haben die fbi-agentin
hier gesucht nach nachdem sie gesucht
haben und können jetzt analysieren wie
viel diese dokumente jetzt wirklich in
der privatresidenz in madrid gelandet
sind jetzt sind die anhänger von
dolmetschern wütend die sind dort nach
malaga gezogen wir haben gerade eric
abgesehen bei fox news der ebenfalls
wütend ist und alle sagen hier will man
jump schaden aber gleichzeitig ja könnte
all das jump nutzen in einem
bevorstehenden kwh offenbar auch sein
profil als märtyrer als politisch
märtyrer schärfen herbert
und neutralen partie schon mit der in
seiner opferrolle die ja oft gespielt
hat politisch gepunktet er verkauft sich
eben als der mann das volk ist er eben
gegen das system auf steht gegen das
mächtige system und hier auch deshalb
immer wieder in einen beschuss gerät das
ist eine art immer wieder spielt und auf
diese strategie setzt er natürlich auch
jetzt in dieser doch für ihn auch
schweren sturm und gleichzeitig muss man
sagen herbert wenn jemand dachte nach
der präsidentschaft von donald trump
diesen mann ist mann los man weiß schon
lange diesen mann wird man irgendwie so
schnell nicht los den download charts
zu bieten und ihm würde man hier noch
nie in den usa danken unseren us
korrespondent herbert bauernebel nach
lauterbach ist immer noch krank hat
corona ist in isolation zu hause und
liefert trotzdem kräftig stoffe
diskussion bei der verwirrung stiftete
es geht um die 3 monats regel die ja ab
herbst gelten soll diese umstrittene
diese neue lauterbach regel nach drei
monaten nach der impfung gilt man schon
nicht mehr als geimpft lauterbach hat zu
dieser regel jetzt vom krankenhaus
getwittert und zwar dass hier das
schreibt er also glauben sie im ernst
dass menschen sich alle drei monate
impfen lassen um ohne maske in ein
restaurant zu gehen und dann schickt er
dahinter
ich glaub 7 fragezeichen das stiftet
neue verwirrung sagt unser bild meinung
schiff für die partie im studio warum ja
absolut also es geht ja um die frage wie
oft sollen menschen sich künftig impfen
lassen dass corinna gesetz dessen
entwurf karl lauterbach ja letztens
vorgelegt hat liegt genau das nahe da
ist es nämlich wer ins restaurant geht
und keine maske tragen will der braucht
eine frische impfung also eine impfung
die höchstens drei monate alt das haben
die menschen zu recht als hinweis darauf
verstanden dass sie sich alle drei
monate impfen lassen um diesen krone
regeln zu entgehen karl lauterbach
bestreitet das jetzt und sagt quatsch
niemand empfiehlt eine 3 also eine
impfung im drei monats takt und hat sich
hier mit einem journalisten auf twitter
angelegt und sagt wer lässt sich denn
alle drei monate impfen um ins
restaurant zu gehen das passiert nicht
und dann schiebt er noch hinterher
und wenn wir sehen würden dass das
passiert dann machen wir diese ausnahme
wieder dicht dabei hat er doch gesagt er
wählt das als anreiz für die impfung
haben ganz genau als er diesen
gesetzentwurf vorgestellt hat hat er in
der ard erklärt diese regelung sei ein
guter impfen bereits den wm ball kurz
reinhören
das ist in den bars und in den
restaurants die ausnahme gibt dass
manfred geimpft oder genesen sein kann
das ist ein anreiz für die impfung also
das ist
absolut offenbar merkt er dass dort
mindestens kommunikativ etwas komplett
aus dem ruder gelaufen ist denn man kann
den menschen ja nicht sagen hey wenn ihr
geimpft sein und die impfung ist
höchstens drei monate alt dann müsst ihr
im restaurant keine maske tragen und
wenn die menschen sich dann wundern na
ja soll ich mich jetzt alle drei monate
impfen lassen dann sagt der
gesundheitsminister plötzlich nein das
war noch nie so gemeint und dann bleibt
wirklich die frage was meint ihr denn
mit dem zweiten teils industrie zwar
sagte wenn wir sehen dass sich menschen
drei alle drei monate entlassen dann
heben wir die ausnahmeregelungen für sie
wieder auf ich habe heute versucht das
bundesgesundheitsministerium zu fragen
was was meint ihr denn damit wird die
ausnahmeregelung für frischgemüse wieder
aufgehoben dass sie also auch maske
tragen müssen dass das denn zu verstehen
was der minister vom krankenbett
twittert aber da hieß es nur zurück der
tweet so selbsterklärend geht so ich
muss sagen je länger wir darüber reden
ich finde da jetzt dafür wird er blickt
man in richtung herbst philipp deswegen
bitte einmal serviceleistungen erbringen
fast für mich einmal zusammen muss ich
mich jetzt noch mal impfen gehen was
gilt für mich in einem im herbst ist es
ganz leicht und simpel zu beantworten
selbstverständlich nicht nur vertrieben
wird na ja so schön es wäre schön das
wünschen sich glaube ich sehr viele
bürger also es gibt derzeit von der
ständigen impfkommission von der stiko
keine empfehlung für dich für eine
vierte impfung die empfiehlt das bislang
nur über 70-jährigen bürgern die frage
ist also was ist mit dem gesamten rest
karl lauterbach wünscht sich natürlich
auch wenn es vielleicht nicht ganz offen
sagt dass die stiko die vierte impfung
für alle bürger empfiehlt oder zumindest
auch für viele menschen unter 70 unter
60 er selbst ist ja beispielsweise
vierfach kämpft dennoch hat ihn corona
erwischt die impfungen die vierte
informiert jetzt mehr als drei monate
zurück hieß es aus dem bmg dennoch hat
es karl lauterbach erwischt auch nicht
symptomfrei er hat jetzt getwittert das
ist dass er sich auf dem wege der
besserung befindet schauen wir noch mal
kurz rein hatte nämlich gerade erst fünf
minuten etwa ist das alt karl lauterbach
also vom krankenbett aus fleißig bei
twitter da hat er eine ganze reihe von
frischen corona tests getwittert das ist
noch der alte das ist das neue ding und
die korona tests können wir gleich noch
mal drauf gucken und hier sagt er dann
eben die letzten vier tage langsam
geht's aufwärts aber corona ist keine
kleinigkeit wissen wir trotz vier
impfungen und pavlov sieht hätte ich
stärker hat die stärkere symptome als
erwartet da können wir unten drauf
gucken auf die striche dort die werden
so langsam etwas blasser bei karl
lauterbach ja und jetzt eben zur frage
was was gilt zurzeit ist eben geplant
dass man in restaurants im kino im
museum maske tragen muss oder einen
frischen test vorliegen muss wenn man
eben nicht frisch geimpft ist wenn die
impfung also älter als drei monate alt
ist und zwar eben die vierte impfung ob
das sich durchsetzt ist eine andere
frage denn damit das überhaupt erstmal
gesetzt wird braucht es eine mehrheit im
parlament und wir hören dass es aus der
fdp-fraktion deren justizminister
buschmann diese regelung mit der
arbeitet hat durchaus widerstand gibt
weil die sagen verzeihung alle drei
monate sich impfen lassen um dann im
restaurant nicht maske zu tragen während
unsere nachbarn sich wirklich einfach
komplett verabschieden von ihrem chor
ohne regeln wollen wir jetzt noch mal
eins drauf satteln und die bürger weiter
mit diesen regelungen malträtieren das
geht einfach nicht deswegen es bleibt
spannend aber ich machte mich jetzt
überhaupt noch keine prognose was im
herbst gelten wird ja ich glaube es ist
mehr als seriös genau das zu tun nämlich
noch keine prognose abzugeben du wissen
trotzdem auflaufen denn natürlich halten
damit wir alle wissen an welche regeln
wir uns denn dann wird eher schon
patrizia auf den fall der uns immer noch
so wahnsinnig auf für den fall ai liegen
je mehr unsere reporter in diesem fall
dieser 14-jährigen die getötet wurde von
einem verurteilten
sexualstraftäter je mehr unsere reporter
in diesem fall recherchieren umso
deutlicher wird das bild das große
versagen der justiz in diesem fall
ein mann in einem zug sein arm lehnt
lässig auf der kopfstütze der mann dreht
sich zu seiner rückbank um zu seinem
potenziellen opfer dieses foto
aufgenommen von einem 14-jährigen
mädchen weil sie sich von diesem mann
belästigt fühlt von jan hajek opi
alliance mutmaßlichen mörder märz 2022
die 14 jährige julia steht mit ihrer
kleinen schwester am bahnhof
brandoberndorf die mädchen sind auf dem
weg zu ihrer großmutter julias vater
schildert exklusiv in bild was geschieht
am bahnhof ist ihr schon der mann
aufgefallen der wahrscheinlich schon auf
kleine mädchen gewartet hat er kommt
ihnen immer näher im zuge setzten sich
die mädchen weit weg von jan heiko p
doch er folgt ihnen wirft ihnen einen
ball zu möchte er sie töten ja ne kopie
beugt sich zu julia herunter bedrängt
sie in diesem moment nimmt julia das
foto ihres verfolgers auf doch jan hajek
op ist nicht zu stoppen er hat meine
tochter begreift er hat ihr auf den po
gehauen
mit hilfe von julias handyfoto kann der
vater jan heiko identifizieren meldet
ihn bei der polizei
unfassbar die polizei sagte ihm sie
hätten jan hajek op bereits im visier
doch passiert ist nichts
mal wieder denn jan heiko ps ermittlungs
liste ist lang immer wieder soll er
kinder belästigen konsequenzen hatte das
meist nicht schon als kind so jan hajek
op kleine mädchen im schwimmbad taunus
perle belästigt haben die freibad
pächterin stellt ihn damals zur rede
doch jan hajek op ist unbelehrbar neun
jahre später fällt jan hajek op über ein
elfjähriges mädchen her hier wirkte das
kleine mädchen fast zu tode versucht es
zu vergewaltigen ein richter verurteilte
an heiko p unter anderem wegen
versuchter vergewaltigung der damals
jugendliche kommt in die psychiatrische
klinik zehn jahre später kommt hier an
heiko p aus der klinik als
rückfallgefährdeter sexualstraftäter
steht er für drei jahre unter
führungsaufsicht
trotz behördlicher beobachtung reißt die
an heiko p nach berlin und bedrängt
schlager star annemarie eilfeld ein
bekannter erzählt bild exklusiv jan
hajek op soll seine ex freundin
vergewaltigt haben sie erstattet anzeige
doch das verfahren wird ein
im januar 2020 endet die
führungsaufsicht des triebtäters diese
soll eigentlich verlängert werden doch
jan hajek op beschwert sich das gericht
verlängert die beobachtung nur für zwei
jahre
doch nur wenige monate später soll jan
hajek opi erneut zuschlagen in einem
garten soll er ein zwölfjähriges mädchen
belästigt haben seine mutter soll jan
hajek op daraufhin angezeigt haben kein
grund für die behörden die
führungsaufsicht zu verlängern im januar
2022 läuft diese aus unkontrolliert
treibt sich am heck op weiter durch
deutschland
auf einem fest in hessen solle eine 17
jährige massiv bedrängen und ihr
nachstellen folgt er sogar bis zu ihrer
schule das mädchen zeigt ihn an nach
bild informationen gibt es lediglich
eine gefährderansprache dann der
grausame mord an eileen am 29 juli
nehmen ermittler den 29 jährigen fest
mutmaßlich soll er die 14-jährige online
geködert verschleppt und ermordet haben
ihre leiche finden die ermittler im
teufelssee wenige kilometer von jan
heiko ps wohnort entfernt nur 29 jahre
auf der welt und mindestens zwölfmal
soll jan hajek op kinder und frauen
belästigt bedrängt und nun mutmaßlich
ermordet haben in aller öffentlichkeit
begeht jan heiko p seine taten als fühle
er sich sicher und geschützt im schatten
des deutschen justizsystems
unglaublich da war auch sicher wir
sprechen mit thorsten schleich
vorsitzender richter im schöffengericht
dinslaken und autor ja sie haben bücher
darüber geschrieben wie unser
justizsystem versagt und beim fall al
deen
ist man wirklich fragen und fassungslos
bleibt man zurück wenn man auch diese
chronologie dieses monsters sich
anschaut wie konnte es dazu kommen sind
ist unsere justiz der irgendwie sind da
die hände gebunden brauchen wir andere
gesetze andere regeln oder gehen wir
einfach zu großzügig mit solchen
menschen um
meiner meinung nach brauchen wir vor
allen dingen zunächst eine
gesetzesänderung wir müssen dafür sorge
tragen können das bereits bei der ersten
verurteilung eines pädophilen
sexualstraftäters eine unbefristete
führungsaufsicht ausgesprochen werden
darf so dass diese dann auch bis zu
seinem lebensende unter staatlicher
kontrolle bleibt wer mache sei auf sicht
dann ganz kurz wer wehrmacht diese
aufsicht ist das polizeiliche aufsicht
führungsaufsicht bis wir unseren
zuschauern noch mal ganz kurz erklären
ja die führungsaufsicht ist die aufsicht
die vom gericht ausgeführt wird das
heißt also bei der führungsaufsicht
bleibt immer in der regel ein richter
als führungs obere führungsaufsicht da
und er kriegt natürlich daneben auch der
verurteilte ein bewährungshelfer nachdem
er sich natürlich auch zu richten an mit
dem er zusammen zu arbeiten hat das
heißt das gericht behält die
führungsaufsicht in der hand
reicht das denn aus reicht es aus ich
weiß auch nicht genau vielleicht können
sie uns das mal erklären wie das abläuft
das und sollen wir das in diesem fall
gesehen da ab und zu mal jemand
vorbeikommt und klingelt und quasi nur
die nachricht mitbringt war haben sich
im auge der mann dann aber im internet
machen kann was er will
junge frauen mädchen kinder anschreiben
kann reicht es aus oder braucht es noch
mehr wissen wir vielleicht auch mal
irgendwie an die heilige kuh datenschutz
seien
die datenschutz kuh ist tatsächlich eine
die geschlachtet werden muss in diesem
fall sehe ich genauso wie sie das
problem ist folgendes die
führungsaufsicht oder einem
bewährungshelfer den ich gerade erklärt
habe der bund wird das ist ein
sozialarbeiter der dem ambulanten
sozialen dienst der justiz angehört und
da wie bei fast allen bereichen justiz
haben wir eine unterbesetzung das heißt
es kommt auch immer darauf an wie viele
klienten hat der bewährungshelfer um
sich um die einzelne person kümmern zu
können wie viel zeit bleibt ihm und
natürlich auch auf das persönliche
engagement
es besteht aber die möglichkeit einem
verurteilten bestimmte weisungen zu
erteilen zb die weisung sich bestimmten
gruppen von personen und in schweren
opfern gar nicht zu nähern wenn er
dagegen verstößt ist das ein verstoß
gegen eine weisung der führungsaufsicht
das ist sogar eine eigene straftat
allein deshalb könnte jemand er unter
führungsaufsicht steht erneut angeklagt
und verurteilt werden da hat man also
durchaus mittel und wege um das ganze
auch mit einem scharfen schwert zu an
wir berichten jetzt seit tagen immer
wieder über die es ist auch justiz
versagen in diesem fall eileen und
täglich kommen neue informationen die
genau das stützen dass es sich eben um
massives versagen dort auch der justiz
handelt in diesem fall aline wer wird
eigentlich dafür zur rechenschaft zur
verantwortung gezogen ich möchte nicht
dass der gutachter heute morgen weitere
solche viel gutachten spricht möchte
nicht dass der richter noch mal daneben
liegt in naher zukunft also wer wird
dafür zur verantwortung gezogen niemand
das problem ist dass wir haben hier
einen richter am amtsgericht wetzlar der
dieses gefährdungspotenzial ganz
offenbar richtig eingeschätzt hat und
der deswegen auch eine unbefristete
führungsaufsicht angeordnet hat dagegen
hat er verurteilt wird dann beschwerde
eingelegt und das landgericht limburg
hat auf die beschwerde des verurteilten
hin diesen beschluss abgeänderten gesagt
eine reine verlängerung um weitere zwei
jahre reichen vollkommen aus hat also
dieses gefährdungspotenzial falsch
eingestuft das heißt also da müsste
zunächst einmal geklärt werden ob
möglicherweise da ein großer fehler
gemacht worden ist ja und dann also wird
derjenige wenn da ein großer fehler
gemacht wurde danach richters jahr wird
er zur verantwortung gezogen oder läuft
business as usual einfach weiter hier
schöne deutschland das große problem ist
dass sie ein richter der im rahmen
seiner möglichkeiten entscheidet nicht
so ohne weiteres zur verantwortung
ziehen können das ist einerseits der
unabhängigkeit der justiz geschult und
andere als auch dessen dass ich habe in
meinen büchern mehrmals beschrieben auch
sehr oft davor zurückgeschreckt wird
dass eine überprüfung auch eine
überprüfung der eigenen
entscheidungen in der justiz immer
wieder mit arroganz abgelehnt wird
unglaublich vielen herzlichen danke
ihnen für ihre einschätzung zu diesem
thema lean und wenn man sich die
chronologie des mutmaßlichen täters
ansieht dann bleibt dann mit großer
fassungslosigkeit zurück danke ihnen
sehr für das gespräch thorsten schleife
die in diesen heißen tagen wird der
berliner feuerwehr ausgerechnet das
trinkwasser rationiert unglaubliche
geschichte die feuerwehrleute von berlin
mensch das ist ja eine truppe die einen
der härtesten jobs macht den hier in
deutschland überhaupt so gibt sie
erinnern sich gerade erst im so
komplizierten einsatz bei dem großbrand
im munitionslager im berliner grunewald
da waren die feuerwehrleute bei dieser
irren hitze wirklich bis zur absoluten
erschöpfung im einsatz an jetzt kommt
der hammer die politik hier in berlin
gekürzt genau diesen feuerwehr helden
jetzt das trinkwasser das ist wirklich
eine unglaubliche story normalerweise
kriegt jede wache reichlich
mineralwasser na klar zum durst löschen
in den schweißtreibenden einsetzen aber
dieses trinkwasser das wird jetzt
rationiert begründung kein geld mehr da
hier sieht man dass kein geld für wasser
mehr da steht in rot runter die berliner
feuerwehr helden den berlin jetzt nicht
mal mehr wasser bezahlen will zum
trinken darüber sprechen wir mit manuel
bartsch vom berliner landesverband der
deutschen feuerwehr gewerkschaft größe
herzlich erbat wie stark fühlen sie sich
da gewerk schätzt gewertschätzt als
feuerwehrmann
ja also ich denke mal zur klarheit
gehört jetzt natürlich auch zu sagen was
ist denn passiert und was liegt denn da
jetzt wirklich vor es ist so dass die
haushaltstitel für diesen bedarf an
einsatzstellen wasser er seit jahren
nicht so genehmigt wird wieder beantragt
wird also in diesem jahr ist es so dass
es gerade mal ein drittel des bedarfs
genehmigt wurde einst das was die
berliner feuerwehr beantragt hat man
muss auch dazu sagen dass dennoch
die führungs dienste also ich einsatz
der dann einsetzt wenn die möglichkeit
haben auch unabhängig des erschöpften
haus als titels auf einkäufe und auf
mineralwasser zurückzugreifen weil so
was ich damit sagen will ist es
wird da nichts rationiert ist es auch
nicht wirklich der hahn abgedreht
sondern wir haben letztendlich wieder
ein budget problem was aber schon seit
jahren intern durch die feuerwehr
verstärkt den ausgeglichen würde also
nicht ganz neues problem was aber schön
ist an der stelle oftmals ist es ja so
dass etwas schlechtes auch was gutes zu
beleuchten wie den allgemeinen die
einsatzstellen versorgung organisiert
und auf und genau darum geht es ja herr
barth sie sagen jetzt wird nicht
rationiert ist ja völlig klar da wird
niemand verdursten im einsatz das ist
klar es geht um wertschätzung in dieser
frage um die ausstellung derer die halt
jeden tag einen harten job machen
deswegen auch meine frage wie sehr
fühlen sie sich da als feuerwehrmann
gewertschätzt das ist eine frage von
respekt der die wertschätzung also wer
wer aufmerksam die medien in den letzten
wochen beobachtet hat es ist schon
schwierig und selbst die personal
versagen ging durch die bietet die
wertschätzung bzw die die kollegen sind
sind dadurch also der vertrauensverlust
der in den langen vergangenen monaten
und jahren stark sein der muss erst
wieder aufgebaut werden die das gefühl
der wertschätzung im allgemeinen ist
kaum noch spürbar
sie kann als seien wir sehen wie sehr
die kolleginnen und kollegen im einsatz
sind werden den großbrand ja jetzt in
den letzten tagen erwähnt wo tag und
nacht durchgearbeitet wurde und sie
sagen jetzt abgesehen vom mineralwasser
das ist ein punkt den wir uns
herausgenommen haben bei dem ehrlich
gesagt bei uns die alarmglocken losging
weil ich finde das gehört zum
grundsätzlichen dass man schaut dass die
kollegen gut ausgestattet sind dass sie
alles haben um diesen knochenjob leisten
zu können jetzt sind sie hier heute bei
uns und sagen auch die wertschätzung
henzi wir mit der wertschätzung aus der
glauben die kolleginnen und kollegen
eher schon gar nicht mehr dran
ja genau also wie gesagt dafür ist in
der vergangenheit zu viel passiert dafür
gab es viel zu viele versprechungen und
auf der einen seite aber letztendlich
dann das fehlende durchhalten an der
anderen seite und ja alleine wie gesagt
bei dem haushaltstitel wenn wir davon
sprechen dass nur also der bedarf oder
erkannt wie man braucht um wenigstens
einsatzstellen was sagen damit legen auf
deutsch gesagt nicht aus der pfütze
laufen müssen um da einsatzstellen
wasser rann zu kriegen und wenn sie dann
nur ein drittel bekommen weil es heißt
wir müssen sparen dann ist es sicherlich
die die falsche ecke wie an so vielen
falschen die feuerwehr wird immer nur
gesehen wenn sie dann just in dem moment
gebraucht wird wenn sie meine stunde
nichts zu tun hat wird es dann gerne die
sitzen nur um und da an diesem image
müssen wir vielleicht auch seitens der
politik ein bisschen arbeiten dass es
eben genau darum geht die feuerwehr
vorzuhalten und dem entsprechend
auszurüsten mit allen möglichen was es
braucht und auch beim grunewald haben ja
gesehen dass es mit der einsatzstellen
verpflegung da ging es ja dann auch
nicht nur im wasser sondern auch um was
zu essen also man kann ja nicht erst
nach dem halben tag feststellen dass da
menschen arbeiten die natürlich auch mal
was zu essen brauchen dort stundenlang
beschäftigt sind und die organisation an
der stelle einfach verbessern
das kann ich ihnen ganz konkret nicht
sagen was ich weiß was ich gehört habe
ist dass es am falschen standort erst
mal angefahren wurde und dass dieses mal
vorne direkt an der an der spitze im
grunde nicht in den genuss gekommen sind
und deswegen werde ich da von
einsatzorganisationen da gibt es im
haushalts- titel dieses jahr tatsächlich
auch entsprechend dass fahrzeuge die
sogar genehmigt wurden sie haben ein
ganz klein hat und herr barth weil uns
wurde immer gesagt bei den ganzen presse
statement alles super läuft ja alles 1a
bei dem einsatz das heißt die die da bis
zur erschöpfung bis in die nacht rein
und unter großer gefährdung im einsatz
waren im grunewald hier hatten erst mal
nichts zu essen sie hatten eine zeit
lang eine zusatzversorgung zusatz
verfliegen und das ist richtig das ist
auch seitens der feuerwehr durchaus
aufgenommen und auch mitgeteilt wurde
aber wie gesagt es sind halt immer
wieder diese kleinigkeiten die das
vertrauen dann schmälern und sie
sprachen das an die wertschätzung finde
ich auch keine kleinigkeit bei 35 grad
zu schuften unter nicht mal was über
essen zu kriegen da bleiben wir dran an
dem thema herr barth vielen herzlichen
dank ihnen für diese information ich
danke ihnen das ist gut so
[Musik]